now we can speak to Sivan vines who's a
journalist and author of Hong Kong
China's new colony he's also in Hong
Kong and is joining us live now as Sivan
thank you very much indeed for joining
us and we are almost drowning aren't we
in this sea a torrent of Statistics I'm
wondering how much confidence how much
faith do you have in the transparency in
the reporting of the numbers by the
Chinese authorities well I mean as we
just heard from from Adrian Brown there
there is definitely scepticism over
these figures when the criteria for
reporting the figures was changed on
Thursday the the number of cases rose
nine fold that's an enormous rise in the
number of cases there is an enormous
question around the credibility of these
figures also there's a question around
the number of people who have died
because they've been told to leave
hospitals even people with critical
diseases to make way for these
coronavirus patients I mean are they
part of the same set of statistics are
they something else the fact of the
matter is there's a lot more people
dying than they're reflected in the
figures that we've seen from the Chinese
authorities and yet that element of
skepticism that you've just outlined
that seems to be completely absent in
the w-h-o for instance the w-h-o has
distinguished itself in a way by by
pouring praise and lording the efforts
being taken by the Chinese authorities I
have to say this is a cause of some
considerable mystery the the director of
the DA uho seems to miss no opportunity
when he makes public statements to Lord
the Chinese authorities for their
competence and skill in handling this
matter there is now a call for his
resignation there's a big petition
circulating around about that and there
is a feeling I think growing that the
w-h-o is not on top of this job because
it's playing too much upside paying too
much concern too
politics rather than the strict medical
requirements which after all it's what
it's supposed to be doing indeed another
example of course that I'd like you to
think about is that that cruise ship
that was allowed to dock in Cambodia
after being turned away by I was at four
or five different ports in the Asian
region but it was it seemed very much as
though Hussein the Prime Minister was
actually wanting politically to show
support for the Chinese authorities
rather than acting upon what may have
been the best interest of his own people
well again this is something that has
certainly been said in Cambodia itself
Cambodia is extremely close to China
very havilland very heavily reliant on
China for investment and and there is
always a suspicion particularly in
international fora where Cambodia or
temperatures is now known I never know
what it's called these days is number
one Ally can always be relied upon to
support the Chinese point of view what's
very interesting though is that China's
closest ally North Korea immediately
shut its borders to Chinese visitors
once news of this maras became known so
the politics here are devilishly
complicated and I suppose you've raised
North Korea I reckon that if there were
to be any kind of evidence of
coronavirus this coronavirus having
entered North Korea a we wouldn't get
any information about it and be it will
be devastating given the infrastructure
of the health system being in such a
poor state well this is the problem with
one-party states who will make it their
business to control information and and
obviously the situation in North Korea
is it's really difficult to get
information out of North Korea very
difficult for citizens within North
Korea to know what's going on in China
itself
they've been tightening the screws again
on the internet having allowed the small
window where there was quite a lot of
criticism might actually say a big
volume of criticism of the local
authorities inhuman rather
so you know this makes a health crisis
also into a political crisis Steven
vines talking to us live from Hong Kong
thank you very much